one of the survivors from the Florida
massacre is crediting the love she felt
from everyone around her for her
recovery 17-year old Maddie Wilford
spoke to reporters for the first time
today I was sitting on my couch today
just thinking about all the letters and
gifts everyone is given and just like
all the love that's been passed around I
definitely wouldn't be here without it
and I just wanted to my appreciation
love out to all you rescuers initially
thought Wilford was dead she suffered
bullet wounds to her chest abdomen and
arm she's undergone three surgeries
since the shooting as John Roberts just
mentioned the man who became the face of
the law enforcement response to the
massacre is now himself facing intense
scrutiny court Spina Phil Keating has
the story of the Broward County Sheriff
tonight from Parkland good evening Phil
good evening Bret sheriff Scott Israel
the man who walked up to the cameras on
evening number one declaring the horror
for everyone that 17 lives have been
taken at this school well two times he
has been elected as the Democratic
candidate for sheriff most recently
re-elected in 2016 was 72 percent of the
vote he calls these demands for his
ouster purely political at a time when
the tears still have not yet stopped I
could only take responsibility for what
I knew about I've given amazing
leadership Broward County Florida
sheriff's got Israel suddenly on the
defensive for the job he's doing as
sheriff of Florida's second most
populous county more than 70 state
lawmakers all Republican have called on
Republican Governor Rick Scott to
suspend Israel who was elected as a
Democrat for incompetence and neglect of
duty less than two weeks since nineteen
year-old former student Nicholas Cruz
confessed to killing 17 people inside
Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School
Sheriff is really acknowledged his
deputies were called out nearly two
dozen times to deal with a volatile and
gun obsessed Cruz but never took it
further
the governor has now ordered the Florida
Department of Law Enforcement to
investigate the local sheriff's
department they
to be completely transparent we have to
do a thorough investigation and whoever
didn't do their job has to be held
accountable the National Rifle
Association spokesperson faults the man
at the top for not using his authority
to arrest crews adding I wish that as
much attention were given to the Broward
County Sheriff and their advocate of
duty as trying to blame five million
innocent and while biting gun owners all
across the country just Thursday the
sheriff shocked the community further
when he said his armed deputy assigned
to guard the high school failed to enter
the freshmen building as the bullets
were flying at this point one deputy was
remiss dereliction of duty and he's now
no longer with this agency that resource
officers attorney pushed back today
saying Scott Peterson was not a coward
and evidence will exonerate his actions
amid reports that upon arriving on scene
three other deputies also took up
positions behind cars instead of rushing
into the school the sheriff says he is
looking into them but Sunday sheriff
Israel said he will absolutely not
resign you don't measure a person's
leadership by a deputy not going in and
more on that resource officer via his
attorney he says the reason he did not
storm building twelve on the day of the
shooting was that at that moment he
thought the gunshots were coming from
outside the building tomorrow's another
day of planning here in the classrooms
for the teachers then Wednesday the more
than 3,000 students returned to their
classrooms where they'll have to in the
morning walk past all of the memorials
the media and that freshman building
still boarded up and a crime scene Brett
let's top Phil Keating live in parkland
Phil thanks